[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans parlement hebdo
l'émission qui refait l'actu de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat est
notre invité pour parler de tout ça
aujourd'hui mounir mahjoubi bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député la république
en marche de paris merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et âme
on va commencer par la carte d'identité
de notre invité mounir mahjoubi vous
êtes né à paris et vous êtes député de
paris élu sous les couleurs de la
république en marche votre domaine
d'expertisé le numérique concepteurs de
sites web ex président du siel num le
conseil national du numérique
vous avez été secrétaire d'état dans le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe en
charge du numérique
vous avez laissé votre portefeuille pour
partir notamment à la conquête de paris
pour les municipales
vous n'avez pas de regret aucun regret
j'avais très envie de m'engager pour
paris c'est la ville où je fus n'est
c'est la ville où j'ai grandi j'ai
décidé de prendre des risques c'est vrai
des risques politiques
je n'ai pas été désigné vous pouvez le
constater mais j'ai l'impression tout de
même que j'ai apporté quelque chose à
cette campagne a aujourd'hui je soutiens
le candidat qui est soutenu par la
république en marche c'est benjamin huot
et puis on a beaucoup travaillé ensemble
et tout ce que j'ai porté dans ma
campagne
ça fait partie de cette campagne
aujourd'hui est donc pour l'heure vous
êtes député dont on va donc déroulée la
semaine parlementaire avec vous du
budget de la sécurité sociale on va
parler il devait être l équilibre
finalement aidé à il manque 5 milliards
d'euros on verra pourquoi il a juré de
dire la vérité et demandé pardon pour
les dégâts le pdg de lubrizol auditionné
à l'assemblée et au sénat sur l'
incendie survenu à rouen le 26 septembre
dernier
enfin le sénat veut protéger les
consommateurs face aux géants du web
le pot de terre petit l'emporter face au
pot de fer on vous posera la question et
on va commencer par le point chaud du
débat cette semaine l'examen du budget
de la sécu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et une partie des mesures d'urgence qui
ont été décidés en réponse au mouvement
des gilet jaune sera finalement supporté
par le budget de la sécu le sujet a fait
débat à l'assemblée lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale compte rendu d'une
séance agitée avec nathalie gloire vous
fait payer au gilet jaune ce que vous
leur avez donné il y a quelques mois on
va leur faire payer
ben en organisant l'appauvrissement de
la sécurité sociale le débat était
tendue dans l'hémicycle dans la nuit de
mardi dans le viseur de l'opposition la
prise en charge par le budget de la
sécurité sociale et non par l'état d'une
partie des mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron pour répondre à la crise
des gilet jaune à la tribune le ministre
des comptes publics temporise pour lui
le coût de ces mesures n'est supporté
que très partiellement par le budget de
la sécurité sociale
sur les 17 milliard d'euros coûté
notamment les annonces du président de
la république sur le grand débat 14
relève du champ et a donc lorsque l'on
entend et lorsqu'on répète que la
sécurité sociale à porter seules les
mesures du grand débat 14 milliards d'un
côté trois milliards de l'autre mais
pour les députés de l'opposition le mal
est fait cette non compensation creuse
le déficit de la sécurité sociale qui
atteint 5,4 milliards d'euros cette
année et 5,1 milliards en 2020 droite et
gauche dénonce un mauvais coup porté au
fonctionnement de la sécurité sociale
vous allez porter sur vos épaules un
lourd fardeau celui de rompre
l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale comme
a été construite en 1945 il ya une forme
d'un sincérité politique parce que vous
fait peser soi-disant sur le mouvement
des gilet jaune le futur déficit de la
sécurité sociale puisque dès le départ
il manque 3 milliards 5,2 euros
pour le gouvernement ces arguments ne
tiennent pas quand bien même nous
aurions retirer cette compensation
il n'y aurait pas eu
réservations du trou de la sécurité
sociale un long débat dans une
atmosphère enflammé l'article a été voté
à une heure du matin
il acte cette non compensation par 89
voix contre 42 alors on s'en souvient
maudire mahjoubi il ya un an le
gouvernement promettait un retour à
l'équilibré des comptes sociaux moins
déficitaire aujourd'hui on est loin du
compte et ce que le gouvernement a menti
ou s'est trompée dans ses prévisions
est ce que vous vous souvenez de ce qui
s'est passé ya un an oui un an c'était
la mobilisation sociale comme la france
n'avait pas la grille très lent trop
ndongue et gilet jaune et au delà et
gilet jaune une prise de conscience de
beaucoup de français de la nécessité
absolue aujourd'hui à ce moment là en
2019 d'avoir des solutions pour pouvoir
vivre mieux et aller jusqu'à la fin du
lieu du mois sans coups sans avoir à
sacrifier sa famille alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé bien le président de la
république après avoir travaillé avec
les parlementaires
après avoir rêvé que son gouvernement a
fait des propositions et ses
propositions tous ceux qui nous
critiquent aujourd'hui la plupart
d'entre eux les ont voté dont vous
dirais plutôt crime
son attitude est hypocrite c'est sa vie
de certaines des déclarations j'étais
dans l'hémicycle à une heure du matin en
disant attention vous faites voter les
choses à une heure du matin
sauf qu'ils ont été extrêmement nombreux
on était très nombreux français soumise
était quasiment complet la droite
républicaine et red est au complet nyaté
n'est pas de débat sur les mesures en
tant que tel le débat c'est que le
financement de ces mesures soit pris sur
le budget de la sécurité sociale et que
cela ne soit pas compensée par le budget
de l'état qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cela on dirait un sujet un peu technique
m'ont dit loi 94 il faut absolument
qu'on change des règles sur l'argent qui
rentre dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale si on diminue cet argent parce
qu'on diminue une cotisation faut que le
budget de l'état mais le budget de
l'état c'est quoi ce sont des impôts
c'est à dire que c'est bien parce que
c'est le budget de l'état qui paye que
c'est pas les français qui payent dans
les deux cas ce sont des français qui
payent et là on a eu une attitude
extrêmement responsable sur les 17
milliards de coûts on a quatorze qui
sont sur le budget de l'état c'est à
dire sur les impôts des français et 3
milliards qui sont dans le budget de la
sécu c'est à dire sur les cotisations
que ce soient pas compenser cet argent
bride je vous dirais que j'ai 45 ans ce
qui est arrivé certains sont en train de
me dire parlerons vertu de vertu ouais
elle et paca était pure budget autonome
sauf que depuis 45 sécurité sociale son
chant hisser est large
elle fait beaucoup plus qu'avant elles
touchent beaucoup plus de sujets et
heureusement que cette extension du
domaine de la sécurité sociale il n'a
pas été intégralement financée que par
les travailleurs il a aussi été financée
par les impôts
une part très importante de la tva près
d'un quart de la tva collectée financent
la sécurité sociale le budget de la
sécurité sociale
il est déjà financée en partie par des
impôts des français libres en fait il y
à du lien et moi j'en suis très heureux
pour une raison c'est que la sécurité
sociale moi je veux qu'ils aient encore
plus d'action dans les hôpitaux encore
plus d'action en prévention n'a pas
encore plus d'action dans la santé du
quotidien des français
et pour ça faut le financer et ça peut
pas peser que sur le travail vous aussi
sur l'opposition l'opposition qui
dénonçait dans une opération qui est là
pour affaiblir la sécurité sociale vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec cette analyse
dans l'absolu ment pas on la renforce la
sécurité sociale c'est contre historique
ce qu'ils racontent ils sont ils sont
nostalgiques de 45 alors que depuis nous
n'avons cessé d'élargir le champ de la
sécu 94
c'était une période où je me rappelle
sur des vous la sécurité sociale avait
un champ d'action beaucoup plus
restreint qu'aujourd'hui les nouveaux
risques pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale a depuis 94
ils ont été financés par l'impôt ils ont
pas été financée par des messages ça
veut dire aussi que le déficit va
s'aggraver là alors ça est-ce que
c'était plus un problème n'est un
objectif prioritaire
il faudra bien quand même contribué à le
rendre moins lourd ce déficit qui est de
l'engagement du gouvernement depuis et
de notre majorité depuis deux ans et
demi mais attention dès là était là la
phrase et la prise de conscience du
président l'année dernière c'est à dire
que cette lutte pour assainir les
comptes publics
cette lutte pour retourner à l'équilibré
et à la faim dans le budget de l'état et
non le vigile la sécurité sociale il ne
peut pas cette lutte ne peut pas se
faire au détriment des plus faibles et
donc il a demandé à son gouvernement il
a demandé à edouard philippe
tout en gardant des comptes sains d'être
immédiatement capable d'apporter des
solutions donc oui ça a coûté de
l'argent mais nous l'avons assumer 17
milliards ça n'était pas prévu dans le
budget que nous avions qu'on se le dise
que vous il a absorbé même lignée que ça
grogne dans la majorité présidentielle
même olivier ferrand le rapporteur la
république en marche du budget de la
sécu il a dit qu'il était opposé tout de
même
non compensation de ces mesures et a dit
je n'ai pas obtenu l'arbitrage de
l'exécutif
écoutez moi j'étais avec lui et pendant
toute la semaine dans l'hémicycle ce
n'est pas ce qu'il a dit dans
l'hémicycle les vérins rappelé en
commission ils avaient pas lui il
n'avait pas obtenu that i cant
commission il avait été la voix d'une
position qui était de dire en général je
demande à ce que la compensation soit
permanente etc si elle n'a pas lu elle
soit exceptionnel le gouvernement lui a
répondu cette non compensation est
exceptionnel il a donc je vous le
rappelle parce que vous avez là on va
s'en dire que verts et olivier étaient
contre il a voté pour
et il a soutenu le cours donc hélas il
monte il assume complètement exactement
même ensemble et ils demandent que ce
soit exceptionnel et il demande des
comptes au gouvernement pour s'assurer
de stars moi je suis encore plus ouverts
à ce sujet parce que moi je pense que
demain la protection sociale elle doit
être encore plus large
elle doit venir encore plus tôt dans la
vie et qu'on doit pas faire peser tout
ça sur le coût du travail et que donc il
va falloir faire peser s'assure impôts
et donc sur le budget de l'état
moi je crois que l'avenir je vous le dis
ça va être encore plus de financement
par le budget de l'état et moins sur le
coût du travail
alors l'autre enjeu c'est l'hôpital le
député communiste alain brunel a revêtu
symboliquement une blouse blanche ce
mardi dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
pour exprimer sa solidarité avec les
personnels hospitaliers nous dire
mahjoubi est ce que pour vous ce projet
loi répond correctement aux besoins
actuels de l'hôpital alors qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de mouvements de grève
dans de nombreux services d'urgence ce
qui est certain aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a plusieurs sujets autour de l'hôpital
ya les urgences et puis à situation
globale du personnel hospitalier et dans
la zone asie vent on a certains hôpitaux
aujourd'hui où les conditions de travail
sont très complexes
il ya plusieurs facteurs qui doivent
nous permettre d'apporter des solutions
la première c'est sur le flux des
patients qui arrivent sur le nombre de
patients qui arrivent aujourd'hui ça
fait partie de toute une partie du plan
qui a été proposé à part la mine
administré par la majorité sur comment
demain
les patients vont être pris en charge
avant d'arriver à l'hôpital que ce soit
pour les urgences que ce soit pour les
soins de prévention que ce soit pour les
soins de suivi faut tout revoir faut
tout revoir faut tout remettre à plat
mais ensuite attention on aura moins de
patients qui vont venir parce qu'ils
seront traités plus rapidement plus près
de chez eux
mais après il y aura et il faut apporter
des solutions aux personnels
hospitaliers et la ministre qui elle n'a
pas revêtu sa blouse blanche sauf que
elle elle l'a revu depuis
plusieurs décennies et elle est une
médecin extrêmement engagée elle dit
aujourd'hui que le personnel hospitalier
qui s'engagent chaque jour pour la santé
des français méritent que l'on
transforme ces conditions travail et
c'est ce qu'elle propose dans son projet
de loi
mais je comprends que d'autres disent
mais attendez vous en parler mais on n'a
encore rien vu
c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont encore rien vu
parce que ça prend du temps de faire les
choses elle a fermé la porte en revanche
agnès buzyn à toute revalorisation du
point d'indicé dur aussi pour les
personnels des hôpitaux de se dire eh
ben on aura pas une augmentation
générale alors qu'ils estiment travaillé
vraiment dur et être sous payés vous ne
demandez pas un geste juste mot mais a
justement sur cette rémunération c'est
que c'est quand même ça le nerf de la
guerre
elle n'a pas fermé la porte au sujet des
rémunérations elle a parlé de
d'augmentation générale et du point à la
hausse du point d'indicé leçon à des
fonctions plus des spinaliens le sujet
ce n'est jamais celui de l'augmentation
générale le sujet c'est de se dire
profession par profession est ce que oui
ou non on a un profil possible vous êtes
ouvert évidemment est toujours et depuis
toujours c'est la même chose au sein de
l'éducation la différence en question
c'est toujours d'aller profession par
profession et de comprendre quels sont
les enjeux de chacun il annonça très mi
novembre on parle de revalorisation
éventuelle des débuts de carrière par
exemple ça c'est à la ministre de
l'annoncé mais je peux vous dire que les
députés qui travaille sur ces sujets
aujourd'hui et vous savez que la
ministre de la santé particulièrement
est extrêmement active a impliqué avec
elle la majorité parlementaire pour
travailler au quotidien sur ces sujets
allemonière ma joue bien on va passer au
deuxième thème de cette émission sept
thèmes et bien ce sont les suites de
l'incendié de l'usiné lubrizol arbres
[Musique]
les députés et les sénateurs ont entamé
mardi les premières auditions de leurs
enquêtes respectives début en fanfare
puisque ils ont passé sur le grill de
l'orque question le pdg de la
multinationale l'america et rich honneur
résumé d'autres et vieux états avant
toute explication le pdg de lubrizol à
commencer par demander pardon je
voudrais tout d'abord présenter nos
excuses les plus sincères à tous ceux
qui ont été impactés par l' incendie du
26 septembre
il a ensuite tenté sous serment je le
jure de répondre aux inquiétudes
nombreuses des sénateurs concernant les
risques sanitaires de l'incendié du mois
dernier
est ce qu'on ne connaît vraiment la
dangerosité du panache de fumée qui est
qui et qui est sorti et qui a flotté sur
la ville de roanne et ses environs
réponse maladroite d'eric n'eurent les
produits qui ont brûlé ne présentent pas
de danger à la santé outre les
irritations
il n'y a aucune différence significative
entre ce qui a été brûlé dans le feu et
ce qui peut brûler dans l'incendié d'une
maison
face au scepticisme des sénateurs les
retombées ne sont pas nocives
permettez moi juste de vous faire part
de mon étonnement sans faire de
catastrophisme
je pense quand même qu'on est là devant
une catastrophe écologique le directeur
s'est engagé à leur fournir toutes les
analyses effectuées par des experts
indépendants
quant au déroulé de l'accident il
s'affine d'après nos informations
l'incendié a débuté hors de notre site
mais nous devons encore en déterminer
les causes
il est trop tôt pour en dire plus une
enquête judiciaire est en cours
trop tôt aussi pour évoquer précisément
les indemnisations pour répondre aux
préjudices subis par les agriculteurs et
les sociétés environnantes
mais le pdg promet que lubrizol sera au
rendez vous une nouvelle promesse face à
laquelle la commission reste prudente
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de la
réponse du pdg de lubrizol on l'a
entendue dans ce sujet il déclare que
les fumées dégagées par l'incendié ne
sont pas plus toxique que celle d'une
habitation
ça paraît un peu gros quand même non
égoutter sur le sujet de lubrizol je
suis
vie comme sur tous ces sujets
environnementaux de ne prendre aucune
déclaration notamment des personnes
mises en cause comme des paroles de
vérité absolue
la personne les personnes dont j'attends
la vérité ce sont ceux qui mènent
aujourd'hui l' enquête pour la justice
et qui mène les enquêtes administratives
ce sont ces experts indépendants public
ce sont ces experts là qui vont nous
rendre des conclusions parce qu'ils
auront travaillé parce qu'ils auront
pris le temps parce qu'on a fait des
centaines de milliers de prélèvements et
que l' enquête va permettre de
comprendre et que les enquêtes
administratives de protection des
populations vont nous permettre de faire
des déclarations qui elles sont mesurées
quantifiable transparente la volonté du
gouvernement ça a toujours été de dire
on explique ce qui se passe on dit ce
qu'on est en train de faire et dès qu'on
a des résultats on les donne parfois
c'est mal interprété parce que les
critiques qu'il dit des choses parce
qu'on attend des réponses avant que les
états unis travaillent donc c'est pour
ça que ça peu frustré maintenant que les
experts commencent à distribuer de
l'information
on arrive à mieux comprendre ce qui
s'est passé hier les experts et hayal
enquête judiciaire mais c'était quand
même normal pour vous que députés et
sénateurs se saisissent quillan mission
de leur pouvoir d'en quête en mettant
face à la responsabilité les les
responsables diocésains mal lui
j'attends pas de lui qui me disent les
résultats des enquêtes environnementales
mais j'attends multipay s'attend de
quelle manière
j'attends que sa responsabilité en tant
que entreprise qui a provoqué une
pollution qu'elles soient à risque ou
noah risque c'est une pollution ça
c'était il ya rien à dire c'est le fait
de l'entreprise d'avoir provoqué cette
pollution
c'est ce que l' enquête judiciaire va
devoir définir c'est dans la
responsabilité faut savoir s'il d
haguenau long terme ou non qui ont
provoqué un préjudice
la réalité c'est un arbre est judicieux
aujourd'hui la question qui est ouverte
c est ce qu il ya préjudice sur la santé
aujourd'hui il semble dire que nos des
experts disent non des constatations
semblent dire que oui peut-être un peu
c'est ça qu'il faut définir
après l préjudice économique pour toute
la zone l'huile est réel il est immédiat
vous savez que pendant qu'on se parle le
premier ministre avec la mise de
l'environnement son ensemble sur place
pour parler indemnisation indemnisation
public mais attention l'état
d'indemniser en urgence mais derrière
cette entreprise c'est sa responsabilité
je lis merkel est assuré mais elle devra
porter sur ses fonds situés aux prises
une entreprise et un groupe qui va
plutôt bien
c'est important de l'entendre il faudra
qu'il soit responsable
jusqu'au bout on a beaucoup parlé des
angoisses des rouennais il ya aussi
des salariés les sénateurs notamment
lorsqu'ils se sont rendus sur place ont
fait face à tous ces salariés qui disait
maintenant et bien nos enfants et bien
sont rejetées dans la cour de l'école
parce que ce sont des enfants de
salariés de lubrizol nous mêmes on a
beaucoup de difficulté à faire face à
nos à nos voisins
qu'est ce que vous en pensez très
important c'est que ce dirigeant
d'entreprise qui est américain considère
cette entreprise qui est en france comme
une entreprise à part entière c'est à
dire qu'elle est incluse dans un
collectif de vie dans un territoire avec
des familles avec des salariés et que en
cas de crise une entreprise elle a une
responsabilité sociale qui est
d'accompagner ses salariés face à ça
évidemment il va y avoir de la rumeur
évidemment il va y avoir deux localement
de l'attention portée sur ses salariés
c'est à cette entreprise de s'occuper de
ses salariés de les aider à traverser ce
moment qui est extrêmement désagréable
mais ses salariés en ont aussi gros sur
le coeur
vis-à-vis de leur entreprise donc je
pense que il faut que collectivement
niayes mais pour y arriver il faut que
cette entreprise paye alors le même pdg
de lubrizol était auditionné un peu plus
tôt dans la journée à l'assemblée
nationale devant les députés il a promis
d'octroyer des fonds pour soutenir les
agriculteurs et nettoyer les environs
sans toutefois donner de chiffres
écoutez nous sommes des choses de
conclure un accord et nous allons
utiliser le fn a su pour pouvoir
identifier les agriculteurs qui ont
besoin de plusieurs gens alors je n'ai
pas de budget pour ça souhaitons être de
bons voisins souhaitons aider des
habitants nous souhaitons ressources aux
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin dit
j'ai engagé des millions d'euros et et
je le ferai encore plus si nécessaire
nous avons travaillé avec les autorités
locales avec le fms pour identifier des
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
le pdg de l'ocs qui a donc promis des
millions les sans autre précision c'est
suffisant pour vous pensez qu'il va
payer bouteille à ce qu'il annonce
volontairement une pièce qui sera obligé
de payer ces jeux vous la belle c'est à
dire qu'à l'issue de l'enquêté
judiciaire et des avants si il y à une
de déclenchement d'une procédure
accélérée
il aura à payer de façon obligatoire
après moi je voulais dit tout à l'heure
sa responsabilité sociale
environnementale territoriales celle là
c'est celle de toute entreprise
si c'était une pme françaises qui
étaient dans l'histoire je peux vous
avouerez que très tôt très tôt le
présidial responsables auraient
immédiatement dit on prend notre
responsabilité pénale art c'est ce que
vous dites je dis que ça a mis du temps
et que je suis content de l'entendre
venir dire devant lé parlement qu'il est
prêt à s'engager mais je le redis
quand on est une entreprise seule façon
ps avec l'argent et donc il faut qu'ils
sortent le chéquier pour ses salariés
pour les protéger au silence sur la
manière douteuse et surtout si
l'entreprise et son groupe va bien c'est
une entreprise un groupe qui vont très
bien est-ce que cet accident
il faut aussi en tirer les leçons pour
gérer les nombreux sites seveso qu'il ya
en france il y en a des milliers
dans de très nombreux départements il
faut en tirer les leçons aussi alors
c'est quel site seveso font partie de
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui protégés par
les protocoles les plus complexes et les
plus importants à la fois pour prévenir
les risques et deux pour réagir après
les risques seveso c'est la totalité de
la chaîne
là ce qui doit être très important qui
doit sortir de cette enquête c'est
comment un site aussi protéger avec des
protocoles extrêmement avancé très lourd
en ressources humaines très lourd en
ressources techniques a quand même pu
provoquer un incendie comme celui là
alors on semble dire chacun accuse tout
le monde
sagna l'extérieur c'était pas
complètement nous oui bien sûr qu'un
site seveso même si ça vient d'extraire
serait pas dû arriver
donc on doit absolument tirer les
enseignements et ça va faire évoluer
suit la doctrine seveso pourra porter
partout plus de protection et on va
passer au troisième thème de cette
émission qui va vous passionnait on a
dit que vous étiez un expert du digital
ce 3ème table c'est comment protéger les
consommateurs face aux gars femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine sophie primas la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat a présenté ses
propositions pour mieux encadrer les
pratiques des géants du web google
facebook ou encore amazon mais est ce
vraiment faisable les explications de
rien romano le sénat veut mettre les
gaffes à ou pas cette fois ce n'est pas
une taxe qui est en jeu mais des mesures
destinées à aider les consommateurs et à
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs
c'est l'exemple du passe navigo et du
paiement du passe navigo aujourd'hui
auquel on ne peut pas avoir accès sur
les smartphones apple parce que apple
refuse en fait de référence et cette
application dans son magasin
d'applications la liberté d'entreprendre
c'est évidemment très important mais il
faut pas que cette liberté
d'entreprendre
elle se caractérise par l'enfermement
des consommateurs autre gros point noir
pour la sénatrice le manque de
compatibilité entre les réseaux sociaux
on est prisonnier de facebook ou de
twitter suivant ce qu'on veut écrire et
comment la proposition de loi voudrait
obliger ses applications à avoir des
standards communs impensable
économiquement
avant de commencer à essayer de changer
le modèle économique de ces sociétés est
ce qu'il ya un impensable
on a quand même facebook on doit être le
sixième acteur mondial au niveau
valorisation boursière
mais ce serait aussi une fausse bonne
idée pour aider le consommateur c'est
complètement aberrant de proposer ce
genre de choses on a des systèmes
technologiques différents et on hâte
surtout des avantages économiques à
séparer ses différentes bases de données
et ses différentes identification cet
entrepreneur pointe le risque de créer
au final un acteur unique en voulant
obliger ses réseaux à mieux coopérer
entre eux ce qui tuerait définitivement
la concurrence cette proposition doit se
veut comme une aide dans le combat à
mener au niveau européen notamment par
margaret weis tagueurs la commissaire à
la concurrence contre le pouvoir des
gaffes à la proposition de loi pourrait
être étudiée d'ici quelques lignes
manière mahjoubi on va essayer de
prendre ce sujet très concrètement
parfois les utilisateurs sont
prisonniers d'applications installées
par défaut sur leurs smartphones les
sénateurs ont pris un exemple très
concret on l'a entendu aujourd'hui en
ile de france si vous voulez payer avec
votre téléphone votre carte de transport
vous ne pouvez le faire que sous android
et pas avec un iphone déjà ce que pour
vous c'est un problème est comment est
ce qu'on peut faire
ce sujet c'est le sujet des formats
propriétaires et de l'ouverture des
standards
en gros ça veut dire quoi aujourd'hui il
ya des entreprises qui nous propose des
services fantastique c'est mon téléphone
je les aime beaucoup
on aime tous on a tous un smartphone et
on est heureux de l'avoir sauf que une
fois qu'on l'a on se rend pas compte
qu'on rentre dans une prison dorée
quand je prends à apple la consommation
horaire des applications apple du
système apple et des règles que apple
chaque mois mais a joué en 10 ans bah
nous on n'a pas envie d'autoriser les
autorités de transport en france à
utiliser la fameuse puce rfid du
téléphone qui permet de s'acquitter avec
le lac c'est implicitement en cochant
les cochons sans lire moi ce que j'ai
dit au patron d'apple parce que je lui
ai dit à l'époque où patrons de twitter
c'est parce que chaque fois vous savez
je sais pas qui mettent à jour leurs
conditions il publie fièrement un tweet
en dix ans la condition était mise à
jour oyez oyez cher d'utilisateurs
regardez les sauf que c'est pas son rôle
majid il ya des choses que tu as mis là
dedans c'est la loi qui devrait les
définir et c'est pas moi de découvrir
chaque jour
alors je l'interdis des nouvelles choses
ou qui motorise de nouvelles choses
c'est le pot de terre contre le pot de
fer quand même la loi française versus
apple ou amazon ou facebook regarder
rgpp le fameux règlement européen qui
est appliquée aujourd'hui dans le droit
français
tg nos données personnelles du protège
nos données personnelles et qui crée une
amende de plus d'un milliard et demi
d'euros pour les gars facile les
respectent pas et tous
ils ont depuis octobre dernier mis en
place en ligne un dispositif qui permet
à chacun de récupérer ces informations
de savoir où elles sont stockées de
savoir comment ils sont protégés ça il
n'avait pas du tout envie de le faire et
c'est le législateur européen qui a
réussi à leur imposer
oui on doit primer le chemin n'est pas
fini mais il ya un contre exemple hein
c'est juste un moyen une directive
européenne sur que ce qu'on appelle les
droits voisins qui dit que et bien
google doit rémunérer les médias les
médias français par exemple ce qu'ils
utilisent et bien certaines parties de
leurs articles et bien google il s'y
refuse et il dit eh bien oui les médias
moi je veux utiliser vos contenus
gratuitement
sinon je vous descend dans les pages de
référencement sa terreur à tout le monde
savait ce que fait google chantage
google s'est moqué de nous google s'est
moqué des français s'est moqué des
européens on fait une loi qui dit vous
avez cet usage qui est de mettre en
avant des contenus avec une petite photo
et un petit extrait de texte
et quand vous faites ça il faut que vous
payez quelque chose qu'on appelait un
droit voisin aux producteurs de ces
contenus que sont les médias mais ils
ont dit
pas d'accord il ya pas de problème c'est
bien vous avez fait cette loi par contre
nous ce qu'on a décidé c'est que ben on
aurait supprimé tout le monde
donc ils ont supprimé tout le monde et
ont dit ce qu'ils veulent revenir il
faut que ce soit gratuit
venez mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
c'est une énorme arnaque c'est novak
à part dire que c'est une arnaque avait
dit est ce que fait l'état quand il voit
qu'il ya une arnaque et que le lait la
volonté du législateur a été trahie en
respectant le droit honnêtement je crois
que vous verrez respecte le droit on va
quand même enquêter pour voir si c'est
si l'on fait des pratiques il a lancé
qu'il respecte le droit je pense que ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est une insulte
économique majeur à tous les acteurs
c'est un bras d'honneur
mais malheureusement c'est un
contournement du droit eh bien vous
savez quoi
la force du législateur c'est de changer
le droit alors c'est de changer la loi
et c'est de la faire appliquer très vite
en 10 secondes vous êtes parti en guerre
contre amazon accusé de servir
d'intermédiaire sans contrôler toute la
marchandise qui circulent pourquoi je le
regarde je pense que ceux qui sont en
guerre contre la france
aujourd'hui amazon ça détruit des
emplois s'en crée beaucoup mais sans
détruit beaucoup
amazon aujourd'hui savander de des
denrées périmées et ça ne s'exprime pas
sur ce sujet il se faut poursuivre aux
états unis est aujourd'hui amazon eux
aussi se de la gueule du monde
quand la taxe arrive sur les acteurs du
numérique de 3% et qu'il décide
intégralement de la faire payer par les
consommateurs la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale l'a convoqué j'ai
pu le dire au patron s'en sert
je pense qu'il s'est un peu moqué de
nous aussi on va à suivre et on va
continuer à en parler c'est le mot de la
fin merci mounir majidi damas était
notre invité n'oubliez pas les deux
rendez-vous un suivre sur la chaîne
parlementaire oui et bien sûr les
questions d'actualité mardi à
l'assemblée et mercredi au sénat c'est à
14 heures sur les chaînes parlementaires
très bonne suite des programmes et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]